we're here with a man who's been on our
show before
um but I just recently heard that he
used to walk past my old office in La
every day it's preppy kitchen author
John canal
is this true so it's true my very first
job out of college I was tempting in an
office and your production company's
offices were right on the same floor and
I'd walk by every day think hmm I wonder
if true's there if it's the one on
Sunset or something you Pat Boone and
then I was the next one over yes now I
can't believe all these years later here
I am well we're collaborating on the
show in fact you guys ready
[Applause]
okay your story John I'm so excited I
cannot wait this one's pretty cool
because I know you're a halloumi head so
National reports that researchers
recently found a 2600 year old
piece of halloumi cheese and it's got
It's cows and goat milk together but
this was buried along with a mummy and
the thought is that in the afterlife you
wake up and what do you want
a snack
right this was for the mummy but it's
not the oldest cheese ever that goes to
a 3600 year old piece of cheese that was
just discovered in 2018. WoW wow wow
turns out charcuterie was in even back
then you know but have you ever done it
do you ever do this in the fridge when
you find a piece of cheese and you're
just like oh cut
right I mean can you do that after it's
2600 years it's called being sustainable
thank you thank you Ross what would you
be buried with uh oh I honestly I would
say cheese like parmesan I mean I love
it just Parmesan yes yeah John what
would you be buried with I want a really
gooey Brie
yeah if we're gonna go cheese that's not
gonna age super great John I'm just
saying it is wrapped in it's got a
casing yeah yeah well the farm doesn't
last forever either true I feel like
just stick me in the vending machine and
we're good to go all right
[Applause]
Queen Elizabeth left a lasting Legacy
all around the world for nearly a
hundred years and according to Metro UK
that also includes a killer pancake
recipe
so a copy of the Queen's instructions
for her drop scones which is a thicker
fluffier version of a flapjack recently
surfaced on Reddit because apparently
her majesty personally sent the recipe
to U.S president Dwight Eisenhower after
he visited her in 1960. really and here
it is so if you go to our Instagram
you're gonna get the recipe of the
Queen's drop scones and we made them
here today yeah they look amazing
I just wanted to say
pancake is a bit of a stretch look this
is a biscuit right look at that that's
thick oh my is it good okay I'm gonna
try it oh my God you guys whoa It's
almost like a biscuit and a like this is
Dominic Ansel level it's like a Fritter
yeah it's like a pancake and a and a
biscuit yeah it's not a pancake but that
Queen she knew how to make a biscuit
well oh my God you guys you guys have to
try this recipe I've never had anything
like it it is a hybrid and it's
incredible it's a slightly funnel cakey
as well too right I think it's right
it's like so tender
[Music]
foreign